الحرب في اوكرانيا باتت مفتوحه على
احتمالات متعدده فمختلف الاطراف المعنيه
بهذه الحرب بدت تتاهب الى كل السيناريوهات
الممكنه من بين هذه السيناريوهات احتمال
استخدام روسيا للسلاح النوويه التكتيكيه
والذي عاد الى الواجهه مره اخرى بعد تعليق
موسكو العمل رسميا بمعاهده نيو ستارت
النوويه مع الولايات المتحده اتاه بروسيه
لاستخدام السلاح النووي كشفت عنه هذه
المره مجله تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وتدعى
والتي اكدت ان موسكو تطور استراتيجيه
عسكريه من نوع جديد تستخدم الاسلحه
النوويه لحمايه البلاد من عدوان امريكي
المحتمل على حد قول المجرات الروسيه
وتعد هذه المره الاولى التي يتحدث فيها
تقرير من هذا النوع عن تهديد امريكي مباشر
على روسيا وتقتضي الخطه باستخدام الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه الهجوميه والدفاعيه الحديثه
والاسلحه النوويه وغير النوويه مع الاخذ
في الحسبان احدث التقنيات العسكريه ولا
ترغب موسكو في تهيئه نفسها فقط لان الهجوم
محتمل على اراضيها بل ايضا توجيهي رسائل
الولايات المتحده تؤكد فيها استعدادها
لاسوء السيناريوهات وذهب المسؤولون
والساسه الروس على الادلاء بتصريحات تلمح
لا امكانيه استخدام السلاح النووي مشيرين
الى ان موسكو ستكون مستعده اذا لزم الامر
لنشر ترسمتها النوويه الضخمه